johnson mike pochon fatalement walo les
jeunes l anglais ça fait deux trente ans
après c'est pareil
les élèves français sont des cancres au
classement mondial son 32e sur 80 loin
derrière les élèves hollandais suédois
ou danois sont même dépassés par les
philippins et les slovaques temps
d'exane et 60 quelques élèves de
maternelle apprenait déjà l'anglais le
but d'ensemble et de réaliser
l'apprentissage des mécanismes
linguistique fondamentaux de la langue
étrangère presque trente ans plus tard
tous les élèves de primaire ont droit à
des cours d'anglais
problème les professeurs d'école ne sont
pas formés correctement parole
d'institutrice j'ai tellement de la crue
en anglais que je pense que la formation
devrait durer plusieurs années
à partir de 2002 les cours d'anglais
devienne obligatoire en prison
[Musique]
les français devraient donc à trump lui
enscene english autre bon point
en arrivant au collège et au lycée ils
ont en face d'eux des professeurs de
langues vivantes bien formés 65% d'entre
eux sont partis à l'étranger pour
améliorer leur anglais pas si loin des
espagnols des norvégiens ou des
islandais qui excelle en la matière
tandis que ça y est ça va marcher
oui j'en ai besoin pour mon futur métier
qui est pilote d'avion et comme c'est
indispensable
finalement bien ça coûte au match 2 et
si jamais l'anglais vous rebute
n'hésitez pas à prendre une autre langue
exemple les élèves de terminale sont
bien meilleures en espagnol qu'en
anglais 54% d'entre eux ont un niveau
débutant à l'oral en espagnol contre
seulement 33% en anglais
sur les mobiles